oh
[Musique]
bon
c'est une manière de s'affirmer comme
camonais tout d'abord pour l'africain
pour consommer camerounais si nous ne
faisons pas qui va le faire à notre
place
nous avons obligation de consommer les
produits médicaments
c'est une très belle initiative que nous
devons de bréhan soutenir de long en
large
[Musique]
le plus dur c'est le financement pour
l'aspect financier
nous voudrons surtout travaillé avec
beaucoup d organisations qui nous
apporter des garanties
des garanties des fonds de garantie pour
pouvoir accompagner les entrepreneurs
les petites entreprises à ne plus être
stigmatisé
[Musique]